وهنبداها من التصعيد الاسرائيلي في الضفه
الغربيه حيث فجرت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي منزلا يعود لعائله الاسير
اسلام الفروخ وسط مدينه رام الله وذلك
بتهمه التخطيط وتنفيذ عمليتي تفجير
متزامنتين في محطتي حافلات في مدينه القدس
قتل فيها اسرائيليان في شهر نوفمبر الماضي
وافادت مراسلته الجزيره بانسحاب قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من مدينه رام الله
بعد ان قامت بتفجير المنزل وعقلتنا
مواجهات قد اندلعت بين جنود الاحتلال
والشبان الفلسطينيين خلال عمليه الانسحاب
وبالتزامن مع ذلك اصيب سته عشر فلسطينيا
بينهم صحافيون اطلاق جنود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الرصاصه الحيه والمعدنيه على
مئات الفلسطينيين في قلب مدينه رام الله
كما اصيب عشرات بحالات اختناق جراء
القنابل الغاز التي يطلقها جنود الاحتلال
الذين انتشروا في احياء عده في رام الله
كما انتشر القناصه على اسطح المنازل